in war you don't always get to choose
who lives and who dies all you can do
you stand with your brothers come hell
or high water and if you're lucky
everyone makes it out alive I had a good
[ __ ] shove is that guy I'm alive wire
I had a choice between jail or the army
and the stupid [ __ ] we're reading Yoko
you missing the war was already over
Janet's ACV for me to Moses when I said
this you Yoko yeah you'll need divine
intervention on that wall look sharp man
here we go
on here by pick the fire for the three
lines one o'clock my job was to ride
shotgun
that's why they called me cowboy
[Music]
we're going round
good
in war you stand with your brothers come
hell or high water and if you like every
makes it out alive
[Music]
mg I lose one where you go to what is
your mission James
Kenneth sergeant US Army serial number
Romeo alpha six no tell me or you die
James Kenneth sergeant US Army serial
Sarge do me a favor
cowboy day
[Music]
young we gotta get out again
do you know what they're saying we said
I don't I be bow said unanswered not too
low
no tonight I same point
fighters they're ours
[Music]
500 500 firefighters holding him down
dude they're all yours that you wanna
[Music]
[Music]
oh god your target pythons u5s on
standby
[Music]
[Music]
Python 2 5 I've neutralized an enemy
camp fighters
five on c5 that's your police killing us
the Jets are standing down until you
know thank God
[Music]
hey GI we know you can hear us
you are Python to fight
[Music]
mate not night
oh my god
commute oh yeah no thanks I have some
information
Python two five one allied prisoner was
located and released
[Music]
[Music]
firebase echo Python to five this guns
out action now
[Music]
there's fire standing by with snakes
you